hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy
and the president and founder of an
educational consulting company called
reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years
and i find that many people run into
difficulties reading classic
philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well in
book seven of the confessions
augustine gives us a really interesting
narrative
about his own philosophical or
theological development
and he's telling us how
people get
questions problems issues about evil
wrong
and he's saying i myself got those wrong
here's how
my thought processes were going here's
why i was
as he says inquiring into these these
questions of evil in an evil way
in a wrong-headed way
so he's he's saying that he
he heard some some doctrines that were
sort of satisfying to him
but didn't really go all the way to the
bottom
so here's here's what he actually says
to begin this passage he says
you know i i wanted to know where does
evil come from
why is there evil in the world if there
is
god this is a big problem
and you know i heard from some people
that evil comes about because we make
the wrong decisions it comes
through wrong use of the will we
choose the things that we shouldn't
choose
and we don't choose the things that we
should choose and we have the freedom to
do that
and so it's our own damn fault when we
do that right and then god
punishes us you know or the gods or pick
whatever you want the universe the order
of providence
punishes us from making these wrong
decisions so that's our fault too
and augustine says that doesn't really
cut it for me
because who made me that way in the
first place
and you know if we do this in sort of a
traditional uh
christian cosmology you know you can
sort of
push things back and say well you know
the devil
puts bad suggestions in people's minds
and then they follow along with them and
how'd that guy go wrong how that angel
will run
sooner or later sooner or later
you have to push the problem back to
god and say look you're going to say
that god is all-powerful
all-knowing you know he says all all
everything
existence itself supreme existence so
why is there evil this is a big problem
so augustine is going to offer us an
account
of how not to address this
problem and get a satisfactory answer
he says i thought to myself
just imagine everything imagine the
totality of
all created being all that is trees
mountains you know we'd imagine cell
phones and bookshelves and
subways and roads and
skies and pick whatever you like you
know we have a much uh
better you know knowledge of the
universe than
augustine himself did so just imagine
the entire cosmos right
and where this tiny little speck in the
middle of it that doesn't matter
imagine all that now bring it before
your mind is
one gigantic totality
augustine says god is greater than that
so god is kind of like something
you know transcending that
so not all of being not all of the
existence
is in the universe as a matter of fact
created being he says
is kind of like a sponge uh you know
it's full of holes
and god sort of penetrates everywhere so
it's like a super super sponge
um and later on he will say this isn't
the right way to conceive of god but
this is the way that he's understanding
god at that time
so this brings up a big problem
where the hell does evil come from
can it come in from the outside remember
god's supposed to be totally good
god's creating everything
god you know interpenetrates everything
so there's really no
outside for evil to come in
because there isn't an outside beyond
created being
and the transcendent god who somehow
encompasses it
that's it that's that's the totality of
of reality there isn't anything
there's no multiverse because if there
was a multiverse that would be inside
here
so this isn't going to work
it's too bad because that would provide
an explanation for
where evil comes from and then augustine
says
that's a big problem you know why
does that mean that evil is actually
nothing
but wait a second we experience evil we
fear evil
or maybe is here's a really interesting
suggestion that he makes
is that fear itself the origin of evil
is that how everything got started
but you know that that he doesn't
actually you know trace this out that
really wouldn't work because
fear of what fear of
of evil of something that's bad of
something that's that's
destroying corrupting uh perverting
something that is opposed to what
what is good what is you know what ought
to be so
keep these in the back your mind for a
moment now he explores some other
possibilities he says
well we know that there's evil
right we're fine with that
we're not going to say that it just sort
of popped out of nothing
because you know nothing comes from
nothing it's not
just popping out of our fear because
what is our fear of in order to make
that happen
maybe it's god's fault still
so god through his creative activity
created everything that is
but what had he created out of well you
know
another way of getting around this
problem of attributing evil to god
would be to say that you know
god created
everything
are actually not everything out
of some sort of evil
stuff will not even necessarily call it
matter
anything you like could be ideas
could be energy could be whatever you
like
augustine is using you know the term
matter here
because he's thinking in terms of you
know traditional ancient cosmologies
and in terms of of the gnostics who he's
you know targeting
um mainly under the manikin form
but you could you could pick whatever
you like yet the basic idea would be
that god doesn't
actually create from nothing god has to
have something to work with
and there's something wrong with that
stuff
there's some primal original fault sin
blame evil defect
in the stuff and he can't make it do
what it ought to do or be what it ought
to be
and so evil creeps into the world
through
created existence
does that really resolve the problems
well it depends on your conception of
god
let's say for a moment that we're not
assuming that god created everything out
of nothing
that there is some sort of stuff that
god actually creates
from some primal material
that he uses that he comes across
the primal materials got some sort of
problem with it
why didn't he make it better if he's
omnipotent
if he's omniscient if he's all good why
didn't he take that
original goop or latticework or pick
whatever you like
and fix it wouldn't that have been a
more reasonable thing to do
that's what augustine you know suggests
here
so this is not actually going to get us
out of the
the problem um he says
he would not be omnipotent where he ate
not able to create something good
without being assisted by that matter
which had not been created by himself
he says so i went round and round
thinking about this sort of stuff
and i never really arrived at a
satisfactory conclusion this is why
we're talking about this is getting evil
wrong
god creates everything out of nothing so
this isn't going to work
so where does evil come from we go back
to the original point
which is that evil arrives
within being is a kind of
nothing that is parasitical upon
something namely the plentitude of good
created being and it does so through
certain types of beings that is
beings that actually have a free will
that's going to be augustine's solution
to this that he arrives at in the very
end of
of the confessions where he began is
where he ends he doesn't provide us with
a full
discussion of that that's going to come
in other core concept videos this one
was primarily just about
what were ways to not get this get this
right
the origin of evil and so we've covered
those
they were evil comes in from the outside
because there isn't any outside for it
to come in out of
evil comes about because god has crappy
materials to begin with and isn't able
to actually make them work
that's not going to work either either
evil comes about
because of our fear of evil well that
presupposes that there's already evil
there
so those are not going to work within a
traditional theistic
framework you could say well then just
abandon the traditional theistic
framework that's not what this video is
about this video is more
about looking at these these ways of not
properly conceptualizing the problem of
evil